If you can't take the heat, get out of the molotov. That's right, it's time to talk about 1G.
And you've probably seen this in Twitch chat when someone kills themselves with a molotov
in Counter-Strike.
But, where did it come from?
Jaryd Lazar, also known as "Summit1G"
is one of CS:GO's most popular streamers,
but he's had stints on a number of teams in the past.
One of those was as a stand-in for Splyce's Professor_Chaos at Dreamhack Austin 2016.
Summit found himself in the spotlight after clutching out a round against Counter Logic Gaming's Fugly,
winning the game in the process.
Only he didn't win the round because this happened.
But no big deal right? Just take a round and win the map.
Wrong.
Not only did Splyce drop that map 16-19 in overtime. They also lost Dust2 10-16
That meant they ultimately bombed out of Group A with an 0-2 record.
Not exactly a great way to be remembered at a tournament.
Ever since the embarrassing fail, whenever someone loses a 1v0 to a molotov
it's referred to as a Summit, or 1G for short.
Summit, now finding humour in the incident, opened up on what it was like to be on the receiving end
of such an infamous blunder.
Terrorists win.
So there you have it, the next time your team's AWPer walks into their own molotov while their shins melt.
You'll know exactly what to put in chat.
Yo bruh, they have free donuts in the kitchen!
Donuts? Smokin!
Just look out for that blazing inferno in the hallway!
(Blazing Inferno)
1G!
Counter-Terrorists Win!
Molly makes you do strange things.